le public et d'empathie russe qui brûle
ah ouais pas mal ça fait aussi place à
jean
c'est ce qu'ont pu retrouver flamme à
droite comme à gauche auto iv ce que
j'avais lâché les vins pour régler assez
beau je regarde par ici et là oh là là
et dans ses yeux alors plus à arrêter
tanguy et de deux voiles à bath avant
c'est tout tu en perds un met à l'eau
naturellement instant soumission bon
accord
on va passer sur les côtés un attentant
je tente un truc je dois les papyrus
c'est vachement volet papyrus dans le
superbe sa superbe et de la raison je
pense élargir son jeu voilà c'est ça
notre énergie par sa famille vers giroud
la beauce et de papyrus
ces deux marques de cigarettes et le feu
à travers les papyrus 1
c'est très beau cheval ific ça va calmer
le feu l'élite
tu t'écartes un petit peu tu es tu peux
encore l'argentine on se bat on va y
venir
vincent aulide suffit atambaïev j
attends mais se garder ça passe assez
peu avant dans beaucoup de feu
l'impression cela permet de charger et
son énergie à la fin si le sens qu'ils
sont réactives et on peut savez toute la
boîte avait on a envoyé d'armement de
sambre dans le nom n'a complètement
brûlé le médocain s'était déplacé en
voilà nous offrons ici
vient la mise au point dans le coin
voilà la salle a pas de feu derrière et
papyrus devant via les papillons le
bruit à l'ombre des papyrus qui est
intéressant oui parce que sinon elle
seule va bien peut on appuie un peu sur
la droite prennent l'eau près de l'autre
un peu plus continuer à droite dans la
rivière qui va vers la rivière et c'est
vachement vous devant la rivière et le
encore encore à ses superbes superbe
bailly fixe ben non pas trop trop trop
quand même
méfie-toi ans la vache est supposé il en
est la rivière est à transmettre leurs
longs le voile auparavant soit 4 voix tu
vois le reflet dans l'eau va attendre
regarde la rivière je ne vois pas ce
voyage est ouvert à fond la laisse très
bon à ce sport populaire
c'est beau c'est les papyrus ils bossent
et les papyrus à bas bruit ce qui est en
train de brûler sur la gauche soit plus
vers la gauche de la route comme dans le
feu tu as vraiment dit on va voir mois
sans voir encore encore encore encore à
gauche encore à gauche encore à gauche
la voie plus faire faire un peu ferme à
peu dans je veux faire dans le fer
tordus à flat doucement faire doucement
on va bien le papyrus voix d'or
nous attendons un objectif c'est plus
beau de le voir à l'oeil
quand tu vas dans le feu d'intérêt très
fermé regardant le feu va dans le feu
valence va carrément de dents dans la
gauche voulait faire faire l'objectif un
peu voilé pas pu heureusement la voix la
ferme ferme objectif
voilà doit le faire faire faire face à
l'armée je vais faire deux camps il
soutient que veut dire de fermer hier
par le diable là tu m'envoies les
papyrus c'est vachement noir toi c'est
vachement bon vivant ça
pointant on est dans la fumée par avoir
un petit peu de comme ça de shantou un
peu marcher trop serré la main vers les
papyrus tournée adore les devoirs le
l'ombre des papyrus qui flambent dans la
rivière tu vois ta droite cette relance
faisant peut-être un argentin un accord
la seule manière et bon point est de
finir ça voilà c'est vachement peau ça
voilà devant avance de suppositoire 100
points avant cela je le vois qu'ils
finissent par un plan large quand même
s'il voit pas savoir qu'on s'en servir
ça vous regarde on loue la page élargir
est un petit peu peut-être là tu vois
pour faire un plan que la fumée chez pas
parce que doucement tu vois pas vu voilà
voilà comme ça voilà voilà voilà voilà
voilà enfin le vers la gauche ou vers la
gauche de la gauche vient pas d'un coup
j'ai perdu un cousin le tournage autour
de cloche doctor doctor bon je voulais
faire autre chose là dessus ou c'est pas
prendre un second set
on finit dessus ils savent où la rivière
doit la rivière l'aure la voile a pu
voir la rivière on la voyait pas avant
mais là on va te plier on va être créé
dans les yeux dans les yeux dans les
faits - veilleux mois s'est lâché les
commandes de contraste dynamique d'ici
20 ans non c'est quand même la baisse il
s'en excuse pas mais ce que je vois un
contre-jour coc au plan aubin super
jumbo si michel un miroir à temps ok we
do what do - ben nous on arrête là c'est
bon on laisse tomber l'action mais
empreinte m'enfin c'est encore d'y
penser on a le temps ou pas ne change